YOUTUBE PAGE SUSPENDED AFTER HE
PROMOTED HYDRO CLOCK SIKORA
QUINN.
-- HYDRO CLOCK SIKORA QUINN.
BUT FIRST THE EUROPEAN GIVEAWAY
AND THAT IS THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
NOW AFTER KAMALA HARRIS'
DISASTROUS TRIP, YOU CAN SEE WHY
THE MEDIA ARE DESPERATE TO
SWITCH TOPICS SO HER AVOIDANCE
OF THE BORDER REFLECT SO BADLY
ON THE ADMINISTRATION THAT THE
ONLY WAY THEY CAN TURN THE PAGE
IS TO FEATURE BIDEN APPEARING
STRONG, AND COMMAND AND EAGER TO
REENGAGE WITH EUROPE.
THERE WAS ONE LITTLE PROBLEM
THOUGH, JOE BIDEN.
>> LIBYA, WE SHOULD BE OPENING
UP TO THE PASSES TO BE ABLE TO
GO THROUGH AND PROVIDE FOOD
ASSISTANCE AND ECONOMIC
ASSISTANCE, PROVIDING ASSISTANCE
TO A POPULATION IN REAL TROUBLE.
FOR EXAMPLE THE REBUILDING OF
SYRIA, OF LIBYA.
>> Laura: WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
HOW DOES MR. FOREIGN POLICY MIX
UP SYRIA WITH LIBYA?
I'VE GOT TO SAY, THIS IS UNFAIR
AND CONFUSING BECAUSE BOTH
COUNTRIES DO AND WITH THAT SOUND
AT THE END.
SO IT IS CONFUSING.
THE ENTIRE D7 REMINDED ME HOW
HARD IT IS TO TAKE ELDERLY
RELATIVES AND MANY HAVE DONE
THIS BEFORE, YOU WANT TO TAKE
THEM OUT OF RETIREMENT HOME AND
SHOW THEM FUN TIMES WITH
ACTIVITIES.
BUT THEY END UP SPENDING MUCH OF
THE TIME PRETENDING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS GOING ON
AROUND THEM.
AND THE REST OF THE TIME THEY
SEEM BEWILDERED TO THE POINT
WHERE REMINDERS SOMETIMES US
HAVE TO POLITELY COVER FOR THEM.
>> VLADIMIR PUTIN LEFT AT THE
SUGGESTION YOU CALLED HIM A
KILLER.
IS THAT STILL YOUR BELIEF THAT
HE IS A KILLER?
>> I'M LAUGHING ALL'S.
ACTUALLY, WELL, LOOK, HE HAS
MADE CLEAR...
THE ANSWER IS I BELIEVE IN THE
PAST ESSENTIALLY ACKNOWLEDGED
THAT HE THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS
THAT HE WOULD DO OR DID DO.
>> THE SHORT ANSWER IS YES,
PRESIDENT BIDEN BELIEVES
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS A KILLER.
YOU CAN SEE THE STRATEGIC
CALCULATION DECIDING WHERE TO GO
WITH THAT AND HOW WE ENDED IT,
MAKING CLEAR THIS IS THE
REALITY.
>> Laura: THAT WAS THE
REMINDER BETWEEN SWIMMING FOR
JOE FOR YOU.
AND ELDER ABUSE COMPLETE OF SCAM
ARTIST.
THIS TIME THE EUROPEAN SPEND
THEIR TIME PATRONIZING THE
PATIENT ALL THE WHILE TO DRAIN
THE PINK ACCOUNT EXCEPT IN THIS
CASE OF ELDER ABUSE IT IS
AMERICA'S BANK ACCOUNT AND OUR
INDEPENDENCE IS THE RISK.
>> THE U.S. PRESIDENT IS WILLING
TO COOPERATE.
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH LANGUAGE]
>> WITH JOE BIDEN YOU SORT OF
FEEL THAT HE WANTS TO BELIEVE IN
THE TRANSATLANTIC ALLIANCE.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, THEY ARE
HAPPY AND THE PRESS WAS GUSHING.
>> IN ONE WAY THEY HAD HIM AT
HELLO.
THEY WERE JUST THERE SAYING AND
WILL BE A PART OF THE WORLD
COMMUNITY.
>> I THINK WE LEAVE THE
UNITED STATES SOME WAYS THE
UNITED STATES THEY REMEMBER AND
A MORE TRADITIONAL AMERICAN.
PREDICTABLE, TRADITIONAL, BUT I
THINK WE KNOW WHICH WAY IT WAS
WORTH IT.
>> Laura: OF COURSE THAT'S THE
WAY THE WORLD PREFERS IT, PREFER
WITH GERMANY AND BIDEN, OUTSIDE
LEVERAGE THEY WILL GET MOST OF
WHAT THEY WANT AND WILL GIVE UP
NOTHING.
MEANWHILE AMERICA GETS STIFF AND
THE TAXPAYERS COME OF COURSE, WE
PICK UP THE BILL.
BOTH THE MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS, THEY WANT TO KEEP
ENTIRE CONVERSATION BECAUSE HERE
IN THE PRESS COVERAGE, DEEP IN
GENERALITY HERE THEY WANT YOU TO
KNOW ACTUALLY AND THIS 25 PAGE
G7 COMMUNICATE THAT BIDEN ENDED
UP AGREEING TO.
WHY DON'T THEY WANT YOU TO KNOW
THE SENATE?
IF IT IS SUCH A GREAT
ACCOMPLISHMENT, AND SERIES OF
POLICY PRONOUNCEMENT AND SOME OF
THE LOW LIGHTS.
VACCINE PASSPORTS, OH, IF YOU
ARE WORRIED ABOUT BEING FORCED
TO SHOW YOUR PAPERS FOR TRAVEL,
THEN YOU SHOULD BE.
THINGS SOUND OMINOUS ON THE
VACCINE PASSPORT WITH G7
RECOGNIZING THE NEED FOR A SET
OF COMMON STANDARDS FOR TRAVEL,
INCLUDING INTEROPERABILITY AND
RECOGNITION OF DIGITAL
APPLICATIONS TESTING
REQUIREMENTS AND RECOGNITION OF
RECOGNITION OF VACCINATION
STATUS.
HOW WOULD ANY OF THIS BE
POSSIBLE WITHOUT AN ACTUAL
DIGITAL WITHOUT A DIGITAL
CERTIFICATE.
NEXT ITEM, GOOD BUY CARS.
THE RELATIVE LANGUAGE WE COMMIT
THE TRANSITION AWAY FROM NEW
SALES OF CARS WITH THE UPTICK OF
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES.
WELL, WE KIND OF LIKE ELON MUSK
AND I SAID THAT BEFORE AND I BET
HE'S HAPPY BUT THIS ISN'T
ANYTHING JOE BIDEN HAS THE
AUTHORITY OR VOTE OR MANDATE TO
COMMIT TO.
THE BIG ANTI-FOSSIL FUEL
UMBRELLA PROVISION IS RIPPED
RIGHT FROM THE INTERNATIONAL
AGENCY REPORT THAT WE WARNED YOU
ABOUT SOME WEEKS AGO.
BIDEN REAFFIRMED HIS COMMITMENT
TO THE GOAL NET ZERO EMISSIONS
ACROSS ALL SECTORS OF THE
ECONOMIES AND SOCIETY.
MY FRIENDS, THIS WILL DESTROY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF THE
GOOD PAYING AMERICAN JOBS THAT
ARE LEFT HERE, DRIVE UP ENERGY
COST FOR EVERY LIVING AMERICAN,
DEVASTATE THE NATIONAL SECURITY
AND LOSE INDEPENDENCE AND THE
TALK OF BUT EVERYTHING IS GOING
UP.
NOW AS PART OF THIS BIDEN WANTS
NOT ONLY YOUR CAR, YOUR GAS
POWERED CAR, BUT ALSO KIND OF
LIKE YOUR FRIDGE AND FAVORITE
LAMP AS WELL.
THE DOCUMENT REFERENCES THIS
NIFTY ACRONYM CALLED SEAD
REQUIRING NEW SYSTEMS BY 2030.
SO GET READY TO SHELL OUT BIG
BUCKS IF YOU LIKE LOW FLOW
TOILETS AND YOU WILL LOVE PAYING
MORE FOR GETTING LESS FOR YOUR
APPLIANCES.
BUT A FEW GROUPS COME I'VE GOT
TO SAY WILL DO JUST FINE IN THE
G-7 DOCUMENT LIKE WALL STREET
AND GLOBAL BUREAUCRATS.
THIS COMES FROM THE GOAL TO
JOINTLY MOBILIZE $100 BILLION
PER YEAR FROM PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SOURCES FOR MEANINGFUL
MITIGATION ACTION.
WHAT'S THAT?
IN INCREASING PUBLIC FINANCE
CONTRIBUTION.
I WILL TRANSLATE THIS FOR YOU.
YOU WILL PAY MORE FOR A LOWER
STANDARD OF LIVING WHILE
BUREAUCRATS MAKE MORE MONEY.
AND ALONG WITH THIS SWEETHEART
DEAL FROM WALL STREET, THEY WILL
BE CASHING IN AS GOVERNMENTS
"DEVELOP THE GLOBAL GREEN
FINANCE MARKET IN ORDER TO
MOBILIZE THE TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THE PRIVATE SECTOR
FINANCE NEEDED TO MEET NET ZERO
EMISSIONS."
SO IT IS KIND OF LIKE DURING THE
PANDEMIC, EVEN WHEN AMERICAN
FAMILIES GOT CORP BIG CORPORATE
INTEREST BUT A LOT RICHER.
OF COURSE, I DON'T KNOW BIDEN BY
AND WOULD BE COMPLETE WITHOUT A
NOD TO GENDER FLUID BIG CROWD.
THE DOCUMENT TO SAFEGUARD WOMEN
AND EMPOWERMENT BUT AT THE SAME
TIME, SUPPORTING DIVERSITY
INCLUDING A SEXUAL ORIENTATION
AND GENDER IDENTITY.
OKAY, THIS IS THE "ANGLE"
SHORTHAND FOR YOU, KIDS, BOYS
AND MEN SHOULD BE ABLE TO PLAY
AND EVEN DOMINATE GIRLS AND
WOMEN'S ATHLETICS.
THREE MANLY CHEERS FOR GIRL
POWER.
SO WHAT DID BIDEN GET FOR ALL OF
THIS NONSENSE THAT WILL WEAKEN
THE U.S. BE 70 RG COUNTERPARTS?
REMEMBER DURING THE CAMPAIGN HE
BRAGGED UNDER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ALL OF HIS
FOREIGN POLICY EXPENSE WILL USE
ALLIES TO GET TO CHINA.
BUT INSTEAD, HE COMES HOME WITH
A LIST POINTLESS STATEMENT, WE
WILL CONTINUE TO CONSULT ON
CHALLENGES WITH NONMARKET
POLICIES AND PRACTICES.
WE WILL COOPERATE IN MUTUAL
INTEREST ON GLOBAL CHALLENGES
COME IN PARTICULAR, ADDRESSING
CLIMATE CHANGE AND BIODIVERSITY
LOSS."
I'M SURE CHINA WILL BE A PLATE
ABOUT NIGHT.
NOT TO OFFEND CHINA BUT ONLY A
VERY GENERAL PLANNED MISSION OF
RESPECTING HUMAN RIGHTS WITHOUT
EVER THOUGH YOU UIGHURS BY NAME
AND NEVER USE THE WORD.
AND THIS IS A COMPLETE
APPLICATION TO CHINA THEY ARE
CELEBRATING TONIGHT.
A TOTAL FAILURE ON THE PART OF
JOE BIDEN.
IN RESPONSE TO THIS COME ALL OF
THIS, REPUBLICANS ON THE HILL
HAVE TO GET THEIR MESSAGING
WRITE AND DELIVER WITH PRECISION
AND CLARITY.
IT SHOULD GO SOMETHING LIKE THIS
CALLING FOR OUR ALLIANCE TO
SURVIVE WITH THE G-7 COUNTRIES,
IT MUST BE BETWEEN AMERICA AND
OUR FOREIGN PARTNERS, NOT OUR
FOREIGN PARTNERS AND THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
BUT RIGHT NOW, JOE BIDEN IS
PROMISING, HE'S PROMISING THE
RIGHT CHECK THAT HE WON'T BE
ABLE TO CASH.
THEY WILL NEVER GET THE MONEY
FROM.
BIDEN DOES NOT HAVE THE POWER TO
AGREE TO ANY OF THIS.
HE CERTAINLY DOESN'T HAVE THE
SUPPORT OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TO DO IT.
SO WE WILL PUT EVERYONE ON
NOTICE.
WE WILL RETAKE THE HOUSE NEXT
YEAR.
THEN WE WILL RETAKE THE
WHITE HOUSE IN 2024 AND THEN
WHEN WE DO, WE WILL SHRED THIS
DOCUMENT AS SOON AS WE CAN.
THUS, WHEN WE GET THE PRESIDENT
ACTUALLY LOOKING OUT FOR
AMERICA'S INTEREST AGAIN, DON'T
SAY WE DIDN'T WARN YOU.
THIS ENTIRE G-7 EXERCISE IS A
WASTE OF TIME.
IT IS COMPLETELY INVALID.
BY HIMSELF THOUGH, HE SEEMS TO
KNOW HE'S IN A JAM GIVEN THE
POLITICAL REALITIES AT HOME.
>> THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
VASTLY DIMINISHED IN NUMBERS.
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IS FRACTURED.
AND THE TRUMP WING OF THE PARTY
IS THE BULK OF THE PARTY, BUT IT
MAKES UP A SIGNIFICANT MINORITY
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE ONE WHO RODE THAT FOR HIM?
NICE TRY, JOE BUT LIZ CHENEY AND
ADAM KINZINGER MAKE UP ABOUT
WHAT 2% OF THE G.O.P.?
THE REST OF IT IS AMERICA FIRST,
BABY.
EVEN CNN SEES WHERE THIS HAS HAD
HEADED ALTHOUGH IT PATHETICALLY
TRIES TO TIE THE UTILITY OF G-7
SUMMIT.
SPEAK WITH THE EUROPEAN LEADERS
TRUST JOE BIDEN THE RELIEF OF
G-7 AND NATO SUMMIT PALPABLE
AFTER FOUR YEARS OF TRUMP.
BUT DO THEY TRUST THE
UNITED STATES RIGHT NOW?
DO THEY TRUST CONGRESS AND THE
AFTERMATH, LET'S SAY,
JANUARY 6TH AND THE INSURRECTION
ON THE U.S. CAPITAL?
>> LESS SO, LESS SO IN ONE OF
THE REASONS NO MOVEMENT ON
CLIMATE FINANCE DESPITE THE FACT
THAT BIDEN BROUGHT THE
UNITED STATES BACK TO CLAIMANT
PARIS ACCORD IMPRECISELY BECAUSE
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE U.S.
LEGISLATURE WILL GET A LOT
DONE.
>> Laura: HELLO, COURSE THEY
WERE NOT.
HERE IS AN IDEA, LET'S HAVE
JOE BIDEN TRY TO PACK ANYTHING
HE AGREED TO FROM EUROPE TO
CONGRESS.
THAT WHOLE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS
THINK THEY CLAIM TO CARE SO MUCH
ABOUT, THE SAME ONE THREATENED
ON JANUARY 6TH?
REMEMBER WHEN DONALD TRUMP,
HAPPY BIRTHDAY,
MR. PRESIDENT TRAVELED TO THE
INTERNATIONAL, THE GLOBAL ELITES
WERE GLOOMY.
THEY KNEW HE WASN'T A SUCKER FOR
THEIR CHARADES.
AMERICA CAME FIRST FOR HIM.
WHERE WE HAD SHARED GOALS WITH
EUROPEAN PARTNERS TO ME TRY TO
FORGE COMMON GROUND.
THAT MADE SENSE.
McCRONE AND MERKEL KNEW THAT
BIDEN WAS ALWAYS GOING TO BE AN
EASY TOUCH, PUN INTENDED.
IF YOU REFERENCES TO BUILD BACK
BETTER AND THAT COMMUNIQUE IS
ALL IT TOOK TO GET HIS TEAM OF
FOOLS TO AGREE TO A DOCUMENT
FILLED WITH GREAT RESET
GIVEAWAYS TO SPECIAL INTEREST.
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO MAKE IT
CRYSTAL CLEAR, JOE MAY BE A
CHEAP DATE, BUT AMERICA IS NOT.
WHATEVER HIS ENDEARING BUMBLING
QUALITIES, UNCLE CHUCK WILL HEAD
DOES NOT HAVE THE MANDATE FOR
ANY OF THIS.
THE VOTE